The other meaning of in Arabic language if you say like it means he owns the
land. A rub of anything is the one that's has ownership of it.
Miko I I understand Allah is is the owner of everything but how does that really
connect to me?
Here's my question.
Do you really realize that Allah owns everything?
Do you really have that understanding that everything that you are and everything that you have
is not yours?
It's Allah's. Everything that you are, everything that you've earned is not yours.
It's Allah's. And the reason I mention this is because how do we reach the highest
level the highest level of true worship of God?
You know what he says?
The highest level of worship is to see and recognize yourself as a slave and servant
of Allah. It's only when you recognize that he is that you realize that you're no
f feel me on this one.
You only know yourself.
I already said in the previous lessons we learn these names because as we learn who
Allah is, we learn who we are.
We understand ourselves on a deeper level.
But so many of us, we're not true abs yet.
We're not true slaves of God.
We haven't truly submitted everything and let go to Allah.
When you recognize this name, you realize that Allah subhana wa ta'ala is he is the
r of everything and that means meh.
How does this impact my life?
How does this affect who I
am as a
person? All right.
Alhamdulillah.
We ask Allah subhana wa tala for his love.
We ask him for the love of the actions that will gain his love.
Meaning whatever those actions that gain Allah's love, we ask him to make us love those
actions. And I think when we say that we have to understand that u there's there's
limits as well meaning our our physical composition our emotional state psychological state you could love
a action you could love and and and sit down for two of them man you
love it right but it doesn't mean that you won't get tired right and he says
something really profound and I think this is very important for Ramadan I'm going to get
into the name that we're going to study today but this is really
important
immandi
he wrote this book called the hikim and in the book he put all of these
really short sayings that are very very profound and scholars have written extensively on all of
them and one of the things he says is that Allah subhana wa ta'ala he says
that Allah gave different colors to the different types of ibada because Allah knew that we
as human beings get bored very quickly so what he's saying is this that all of
the different that we do whether it's of Allah whether it's dua whether it's reading Quran
standing whether it's helping someone whether it's cooking a meal for the family whether it's bringing
water to your to your father or mother all of these are different iat and they
all have a different color to them they all feel differently and the reason he said
that Allah gave us so many different types of ibada so that we can go from
one to the next to the next to the next to the next so a person
in Ramadan on.
You're getting in that it's like 3 30 3 p.m.
You you like you hanging on by a thread.
You're reading Quran, but then you do a little thicker and then you get up and
you help someone in the family.
You do something around the house cuz that's too taking care of the home.
But you go from one thing to the next, but all of it is done for
the sake of Allah.
This is how a person becomes a true abbid of Allah, a true person that is
always remembering Allah.
See, many people think when we say your whole life should be that we're saying you
should be sitting with a with vicker beads in your hand all day.
That's not the reality.
The reality is if you look at the prophet's life sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he went
home they used to ask like I what was he like at home as if he
was praying all day.
She was like no he did what every other man would do at home.
He took care of the home.
And then she started to even mention some of the domestic things that he the the
pinnacle of manliness he would do at home.
So my I my point is that we ask Allah to give us love for i
in this month.
Uh this is truly a blessed month and there's nothing better.
One of the greatest ibadas is to learn and be and inspire your heart and know
who Allah is.
And that is what this haka is about.
For the last like four months, we have been going through these names of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala with one intention.
The intention is to know our Lord in a deeper way.
So that throughout our lives, we're seeing Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala just in every aspect of
our life. And each one of these names, each one of these names is a way
into understanding your relationship with God on a deeper level.
Each one of these names.
Tonight we're going to talk about a name of Allah subhana wa ta'ala which subhan allah
if you look at the structure of the Quran the first surah is surah fata and
Allah subhana wa tala begins surah fata
alhamdulillah it
begins with
alhamdulillah as if all praise is for Allah and the very first attribute or name of
Allah that we are taught after that phrase is and that is the name I want
to talk about tonight.
Many of us have have said, "Oh our Lord, like oh my lord."
But this word is a very powerful way of understanding who Allah subhana wa ta'ala is.
And it actually begins prior to what's meant what was revealed in the Quran.
Allah tells us in another surah that there was a moment when all of the progeny
of Adam. Every soul that would exist was taken from the loins of Adam and they
were asked a question.
And Allah talks about this in the Quran where Allah says,
"Am I not your Lord?"
It's this moment where prior to our coming into the world, every soul recognized Allah.
But what's interesting about the verse is Allah doesn't say am I Allah Allah says and
that's the name we want to study tonight who is what does it mean that Allah
is and what how does this name relate to my past I'm looking at my life
where I came from the things I've gone through where I'm at right now and where
Allah subhana wa ta'ala will take me or you in the future So this name is
connected to your past.
It's connected to your your present and it's connected to the future.
This name is is deep.
There's a few different translations that we typically give.
The typical translation we give is our Lord.
But scholars break this word down deeply.
The word comes from a root of like is when you nurture something.
When you take something and I want you to look at your life and your relationship
with Allah. When you take something from one stage to the next stage constantly making it
better and better and better and better.
One of the one of the scholars he defines he
says
is
Like is when you take something and you keep making it better.
You keep doing is to it.
What does islah mean?
Fixing it, tweaking it, helping it become better, helping it become reach its full potential.
Why is this name important?
Because if we understand this name, we're able to look for a moment at our lives
and study our lives and understand that if you look closely and take a moment in
this month of Ramadan in these nights and look at how Allah has been nurturing you,
that's the meaning of the one who nurtures the one who nurtures something.
They say with with children we often say you have to do you have to do
of this child.
Typically means to culture the child to raise the child up.
But when we talk about it with ourselves it's often the this the the uh harsh
side of raising something up.
When we study Allah and understand how Allah has taken care of us, we'll see that
it was with nothing but love that he did our ta.
I want to start tonight with a story of Moses.
The Quran tells us in the in the Quran there are so many places where Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he speaks about uh the story of Moses.
And this name for me and for us is extremely important when you're going through transitions
and you don't know what's in front of you.
Life is constantly throwing transitions at us.
You're in between jobs, you're in between marriages, you're waiting to get married.
I I don't know, right?
You're constantly in transitions.
And it's in those transitional moments where we don't know what's in front that this name
comes in. And I'll explain it through the life of Moses.
There's this Moses, there's this moment in Moses's life, Alisam, where he's given this task to
go to Pharaoh.
And he wasn't expecting this transition.
This wasn't on his list.
He was traveling with his family with wifey and the kids, going to see his in-laws.
He was going to see his mother and just spend time with her.
But Allah had a different plan for him.
He arrives at the burning bush as we all know.
And it is at that moment that Allah speaks to him.
Allah spoke to him.
But he didn't just speak to him.
He gave him a responsibility.
He told him, "I need you to go to Pharaoh.
I need you to free Benny is you have a job to do.
You have something that you're created for."
And that's something I want all of us to understand.
Every one of us has a unique purpose in Allah's creation, a unique task.
And if we stay on social media, if we keep looking at what other people are
doing, you'll never be able to tap into what your true purpose is.
But when you start to get to that point where you see your purpose, this is
where fear creeps in.
And by knowing this quality of, and let me explain how this relates.
Moses, he
makes this dua.
He
says, he
starts with he
says, "Oh Allah, oh my lord, oh the one who nurtured me, expand my chest."
Meaning, take the anxiety out so I could do the job that I need to do.
How many of us have jobs we need to do, but the anxiety about the job
is too much?
Moses felt it too.
So who does he call?
the one who nurtures you from one stage to the next stage to the next stage
to the next stage.
He says,
"Make my
job
easy for
me.
Oh Allah, take this not out of my tongue."
Moses had a speech impediment.
His job is to go give da'a, but he has a speech impediment.
So he's thinking like, yo, my brother, he speaks fluently, clearly.
Why would I go?
Why would I be the one to do that job?
So then he asks,
he says, I need a helper from my family.
And he asks all of these things to Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Now look at the response that Allah gives.
And what did I mention in transitional moments in our lives?
This name it it helps us with our future but it also helps us in the
present moment. Look what Allah says to him.
Allah
says
Allah says oh Moses I'm going to give you exactly what you asked for.
Everything you ask for I'm going to give it.
But look what he says next.
And don't forget that I have blessed you before.
I have blessed you before.
I I was working with a with a with a sister like years ago and she
was going through a transition, a difficult moment, 40 years old, older than 40, going through
a transition, and she was worried about job security, all of these things.
And I just asked her a question, and this name connects to it.
I said, "Has Allah taken care of you up till now?"
That's my question for everyone in the room.
Has Allah brought you from one stage to the next stage to to the places you
never thought you would be?
You never dreamt that you would get to that position?
I said to her, I said, "Has he ever let you down?"
And she had to say, "No, he's given me everything."
So, here's the next logical question.
Why would he let you down now?
But I I can sense in the room there's resistance.
And the resistance may come because you haven't taken the time to see how he brought
you to this place that you're at right now.
And that's what Moses was being taught.
Moses in this moment, what does Allah say to him?
He says, what does Allah say to Moses?
He says,
he says, don't forget, look back.
I have already blessed you before.
When was this?
when I spoke to your mother and I revealed something to her.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on. We got to go back in the story.
Moses is born at the time that Pharaoh is killing every male child because he's fearful
that someone is going to take his leadership.
And when when the mother of Moses gives birth to him, she's fearful.
This child will be killed like every other child.
And then the angel comes and says, "No, put him in a box and place him
on the river."
On the river where there's water and there's waves.
Put them on the river.
Let go of them.
Let Allah do his plan.
And this tells me sometimes the route that Allah wants us to take doesn't make logical
sense to us.
But it's at that moment that you got to lock in and have true certainty that
Allah's plan is real.
What's crazy to me is that Allah is telling Moses that I was doing your I
was nurturing you when you were an infant in your mother's arms.
You are an infant in your mother's arms.
It goes back that deep.
Before I finish, Moses, let me come to another prophet.
I told you that transitions are the time that you need to know this name.
You have to say this name.
And when you say it, I want you to think of the one who's nurturing you.
He's taking you from stage to stage.
I'm going to start with a with with with none other than Allah sallallam.
We know his story.
Before he's born, his father dies.
No father to take care of him.
Then he's with his mother for some time and he's sent off to be with Haleem
because that was the custom of the time.
He's raised with Haleem till he reaches the age of around six or eight and Hale
Lima takes him back.
No, you know, you got to take him back.
Something had happened.
Angels had come to him.
She got shook.
You know, it's like daycare calls.
You like, "You got to pick up your son."
Yo, you're like, "What happened?"
Like, "Nothing. Just pick him up."
That's what she did.
She took him back.
So, he's with his mother at the age of six.
Finally, I get to be with mom.
And what happens, y'all?
Mother passes away.
He gets a year and a half with his mom.
Six years old.
You remember everything.
And then he's passed on.
Now he's with his grandfather till the age of eight.
But what happens at the age of eight?
Guess who passes away?
Grandfather passes away.
This man goes from stage to stage to stage of loss, stage to stage to stage
of loss. But how does Allah begin the first revelation that comes to him?
Read the verse in your head.
The very first name that Allah gives him after his proper name, Allah.
The next attribute that he says, I need you to know me.
Tonight is about knowing God deeply and I want you to know him on a personal
level where you see him in your life.
And so, Muhammad sallall alaihi wasallam is at this transitional phase where his life is about
to change. And Allah subhana t in his wisdom chooses the very first name I need
you to know about me after Allah recite in the name of your so tonight I
want us to understand and look in your life let's come back to Moses though Moses
he Allah subhana t is reminding him of everything that he did for him he says
says, "Oh,
I I I I inspired your mother to do what she did for you.
Had I not been nurturing you, caring for you, making sure you go from one stage
to the next stage to the next stage, had I not been doing that, you would
have been dead with the other children of Ben isel that were dead.
But you weren't."
Now, I I don't know about your life.
We We all grew up differently.
But for me, this name meant so much because there were stages that God was protecting
me on levels that I never ever could imagine.
Coming from a Jahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah.
Y'all know what jahalyah is Muslims we have in jahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah these days too.
Y'all know what jahelia is.
But jahyah was rough man.
And we lived lives where at one turn everything could have been different.
And the reason I know that is I have people that I grew up with that
took that wrong turn.
But was with me in every moment.
And that's why they say listen uh um I think it was Josie.
He says a rub is the one that sustains and nurtures his creation.
But he says there's two types of this nurturing.
Listen closely. One is the nurturing that is for all creation where Allah is taking care
of the creation whether it be the sun, moon, stars, ants, animals, all of it.
Allah is nurturing all of that.
That's one type of nurturing.
Everything around us being nurtured by God.
That stray cat that's on your street that shows up every other day for food.
You ain't taking care of that.
Allah is the You know how I know?
Go to Turkey.
There's a lot of cats out there.
They all alive doing good.
You go to Haram, all these cats.
Fine. You're like, "Yo, who's taking care of y'all?
Who's the one nurturing you?"
And here's what I think happened.
When we were young, we trusted God.
We just knew everything would be okay.
I use the analogy of taking my family on a road trip.
Man, when you take your family as an adult on road trip, it's stress.
Yo, I'm I'm driving.
I'm like, man, what if I get a flat?
Do I got triple AAA?
Where's the closest exit?
You know what I mean?
We in Texas, so you got your five.
Yeah. Then, you know, you see weirdos, you're like, I got my piece.
I'm good. You know what I mean?
Like, it's Texas.
Whatever. You know what I mean?
The point is, as an adult, we're always worried about how we nurture.
And when we get in this mode, it's like any of y'all older sisters.
Yeah. Earth, man.
I got I got PTSD from older sisters, bro.
Older sisters are amazing.
You know why?
Because they learned how to do.
They understood from a young age.
I got to I got to pick up the slack.
I got to take care of this.
My point is as a as a as an adult, road trips are stressful for me
because I'm trying to do the I'm trying to make sure everyone's okay, but my children
are in the back chilling,
chilling,
playing games, joking.
I'm like, "Oh, we need gas."
They like, "Yeah, you got it."
I'm like, "Charges running out on the card."
You good? Use that card you got.
You know what I mean?
Like, subhan Allah, when we were young, we understood someone was taking care of everything.
Someone was making sure I'd get what I needed.
But somewhere along the way, as we took on responsibilities, we started to think that we
are the rub.
We are the rub.
And the reality is that if you connect with this name, you will realize that God
may put people in your life that train you, help you grow, but the one really
behind the scenes is Allah.
Let me give an example.
Let me give you an example.
How did I accept Islam?
This is crazy.
This guy comes up to me and he I can't go.
It's too I ain't got time to do the whole joint, but he's basically not on
proper Islam. Right.
It's called 5enters.
It's some weird stuff.
Okay, those who know know it's some crazy stuff.
But he comes up to me and he's like, we're working a job together.
It's like a summer job.
He's a co-orker and he's like, "Have you ever read the Quran?
Have you ever read the Quran?"
And I was like, "Nah, no."
He's like, "Man, what you what are you doing?
You never read the Quran yet?"
He's like, "I got one at home.
You ain't gave me the Quran."
Now, this guy, he lived his life or whatever, but he wasn't on haya and his
lifestyle was pretty bad to be just legit with y'all.
Keeping it hunted, his lifestyle was pretty bad.
But Allah placed that man in my life at the right time because my Allah's nurturing
of me had to keep going.
Had to. So my point to you is that yes, God will put people in our
lives that will nurture us, give us a promotion, hook us up with a contact that
they know, help us out with something.
But you must never forget who your true rub is.
And the rub is the one that got you to where you are right now.
But if you recognize who where you are right now, you'll realize where he's going to
take you. And and and here's what's amazing.
I was going to save this for later, but I want to do this now.
There are two people in the story of Beni Israel with the name Musa.
Two people. One is MS the prophet.
The other is Musa also known as Sam.
I don't have time for his whole story, but the Quran tells us that Sam was
off the track.
He off he was off the track.
He actually pulled Benny Israel into shik or idolatry after they had been saved.
But here's the crazy story.
Sam when he was a young baby, when he was a young baby, his mother and
father died and Allah had arranged for some animals to nurture the baby until people saw
this baby and brought the baby in.
What this means is that the se the the stories of history tell us that in
the beginning this is a in the beginning years of his life Sam Gabriel himself nursed
Sam nurse Samur shake where's this going there's a there's a poem in Arabic that says
the mus that was nursed and raised by Pharaoh became a prophet and the mus that
was raised by Gabriel became a deviant.
Why am I saying that?
If you realize who's truly nurturing you, who is your rub, it doesn't matter who Allah
puts in your life because all of that is part of God's plan.
In fact, when Moses goes back to Pharaoh and he's giving them his me this message,
you know what the first thing you know what the first thing that Pharaoh says?
He says,
he says, "Didn't I nurture you?"
The very first thing Moses says, uh, Pharaoh says to Moses is, "I'm the one that
nurtured you." Now, had Moses not already learned who his true love was.
He would have got tripped up.
But he said, "Nah, you didn't.
You didn't nurture me.
Allah nurtured me by putting you in my life by putting you in my life.
Allah nurtured me.
So Allah subhana t is telling Moses don't worry about the future because the same rub
that inspired your mother to place you in a basket and let you go down the
the river is the same that is with you right now.
So
he
says,
"I was nurturing you when I revealed to your mother what I revealed to her.
I told her to place you in a box.
And I told your mother to place you into the river,
and I will let his enemy take him in."
and my enemy, meaning Pharaoh, bring him into the home.
But while he was being nurtured in the house of Pharaoh, he was truly being nurtured
by God. And so, why am I saying this?
Some of us have dealt with uh very difficult families, man.
Very difficult families where the house wasn't what it it wasn't the Brady Bunch.
How about that?
Y'all too young.
They ain't laugh.
They don't even know what a Brady Bunch is.
Cool. Whatever. It wasn't the most beautiful household.
Dad provided. Mom was there.
But I need you to look beyond what they gave you.
And first of all, number one, first thing first, appreciate the people that God put in
your life to nurture you.
Number one, where do I get that from?
Allah says in the Quran that we need to make the dua
Look at the words.
Oh Allah, take care of them.
Have mercy upon my mother.
Have mercy upon my father.
The way they nurtured me, cared for me when I was small.
So the first way we need to recognize this name, it's on two levels.
Allah will place people in your lives that will be there for you, nurturing you, but
never lose sight of the one who has been taking you from one stage to the
next stage to the next stage to the next stage.
Number two, those people that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has placed in your life that nurture
you, help you in any way.
Ali is such a special companion, y'all.
Ali is the cousin of saiam but he's more than that.
Ali was like the son of the rasool cuz he grew up in the house and
they say the greatest blessing of Ali is that he he grew up in the house
of the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam.
So who did his who raised him up?
But this when we look at his life, we see that Allah placed in in his
life someone that would nurture him and help him reach his full potential.
And that's what I want us to do with this name.
I want us tonight to
say
this
name.
But when you say it, I want you to think of everything that he did to
bring you to this point.
Despite how dysfunctional your family was, you
became what you
became. In this room alone, there are people that have reached the heights of what people
wanted to achieve in life.
But who did that?
And why am I saying that?
Why am I saying that y'all?
I'm saying that because when the future is unknown, the only way you will be able
to have the confidence needed to push forward is you remember how he nurtured you.
And I'll give you another example.
One of the examples that I love is the is is the life of Zakaria.
Zakaria had lived a life where Allah had blessed him with so much.
But he reached a point in old age where he needed he he wanted more.
And that's okay.
This is the month of asking.
Those duas that are in the depths of your heart, you got to ask them.
You got to beg Allah for those.
So what did he say?
He said, notice he started with the one who brought me from stage to stage to
stage to stage.
He said, "Oh my Lord, do not leave me alone."
He wanted a son.
He wanted a child more than anything else.
But notice that it is his understanding of this name Al that allowed him to open
his heart up and beg Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
In the definition of this name Alab, there's a few more ways I want us to
look at this name.
So I already mentioned rub is the one that is the nurturer.
Rub is also the one who sustains meaning the state you're in a rub will keep
you going. A lot of us are in a good state but the anxiety is what
if I what if it goes wrong.
No ar is the one that sustains you in the state that you're at.
So when you say you're calling the one that has brought you here but also the
one that sustains you.
But there's another one yo and this is the big one and it really connects to
this month of Ramadan.
The other meaning of in Arabic language if you say like it means he owns the
land. A rub of anyone anything is the one that's has ownership of it.
I I understand Allah is is the owner of everything but how does that really connect
to me? Here's my question.
Do you really realize that Allah owns everything?
Do you really have that understanding that everything that you are and everything that you have
is not yours.
It's Allah's. Everything that you are, everything that you've earned is not yours.
It's Allah's. And the reason I mention this is because how do we reach the highest
level, the highest level of true true worship of God?
Josie, you know what he says?
He says that the highest level of worship is to see and recognize yourself as a
slave and servant of Allah.
It's only when you recognize that he is that you realize that you're ab feel me
on this one.
You you you only know yourself.
I already said in the previous lessons, we learn these names because as we learn who
Allah is, we learn who we are.
We understand ourselves on a deeper level.
But so many of us, we're not true abs yet.
We're not true slaves of God.
We haven't truly submitted everything and let go to Allah.
When you recognize this name, you realize that Allah subhana wa ta'ala is he is the
of everything and that means meh.
How does this impact my life?
How does this affect who I am as a person?
when uh Abu Talha he was a sahhabi of the rasoolai Abu Talha had went on
a on a battle a journey for a battle and his son was sick and his
wife was taking care of the son and uh he left while the child was sick
and you know he went for the battle and he came back the day that he
came back he came back in the evening time he walks into the house and the
first thing he asks his wife he says how's how's how's how's yah doing?
And she says to him, "He's better than he's ever been."
But the reality was he had passed away.
He was in the corner of the house on a bed and she had covered him
up. So she pointed and he said, "He's better than he's ever been."
She spent the night with him that night.
And in the morning when they first woke up prayed fudger she said to him if
somebody gave somebody a loan and then they asked for the loan back have they wronged
the person when they asked for the loan back abs he says no he hasn't wronged
him that's his right he owns it he can ask for it back right when he
said that she looked in his eyes and she said Allah subhana wa ta'ala has taken
our son back he wasn't ours He wasn't ours.
He is I'm Abd.
I actually witnessed a man go through this in my life.
I had a good friend who I consider a sheh of mine, Tamar, who had adopted
a young boy.
I told y'all this story before, but it fits here so pertinently.
He had adopted a young boy at the boy was one years old.
He adopted him from Morocco.
He brought him back.
He took care of him.
He did his tia.
He rubbed. He was the rug for this child.
He nurtured him and brought him up and at the age of 12 I I kid
you not in a matter of 48 hours he got a headache he said I don't
feel well and about 40 hours after that we were praying his janaza it was the
most tragic thing you can imagine that I've taken this child as my own child and
I raised him for 12 years of my life like my own but you know what
sh the shake said to me with tears tears in his eyes.
He said, "I understood he wasn't mine.
He was Allah's."
And it hurts so much to lose him, but I know he's not mine.
We think we are the RS.
And because we think we are the whenever something is taken away, we think, "Why did
you take what's mine?"
But if we connect with today's name, there's two things that will happen in our hearts
tonight. Number one, you will look at your life and see how Allah has nurtured you,
taken care of you, and you will realize that he took care of me.
He will always take care of me.
Number one, he is the nurturer.
He is the sustainer.
He will sustain you.
And especially in transitions when you don't know what's coming next, that is when you need
to realize he is.
You're going off to do the next thing.
He's you never forget that he brought you to where you are right now.
Never forget that.
And the second thing that we'll gain by this name is if we truly say this
name yah with the meaning of he is the master and owner of all you start
to realize I don't own any of this none of this is mine everything I have
is truly Allah subhana wa tala's and when you reach that stateb he says the highest
level of worship is to recognize that you are a slave and a servant of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala If you are going through hardship in this moment, it is this name
that reminds me that he has been caring from for me and bringing me to my
completion and nurturing me.
And this is what we're studying tonight.
This name is Alab.
So throughout these the rest of the week until we learn the next name, call this
name Alab. But every time you say it, I want you to remember what it truly
means. Look at your life.
Look at your life and see that inside of you and understand that because he brought
you here, he will for surely be your rub for the rest of your life and
take you to that next stage.
And I believe that if you truly connect to this name, he'll take you to a
level that you never even dreamt of actually reaching.
That is the name we'll study.
Uh we have to end a little early just so that we can set up forawi
and get everything set.
But before I do that, hold up.
Hold up. On the screen, you're going to see a QR code because I and we
need y'all support in order to continue growing.
You've seen what has become.
All of our hearts have benefited so much from what Kalam is, but we need your
support inshallah. And we're looking for a hundred people to become sustainers for $30 a month.
What is Netflix, yo?
Yeah, y'all ain't acting like y'all don't know the price.
Please, the QR code is right there.
We need a hundred people to not think twice, to literally scan it and be like,
I'm not even going to think about it.
I'm just going to do it because I need to nurture the place that nurtured me.
I need to nurture because what nurtured me.
That is the way we build these institutions.
That is the way we give back to where we were nurtured.
The same way my parents nurtured me and I'm going to in as they reach old
age nurture them.
The same way the places that spiritually nurtured us, we have to nurture them.
So please take out your phone.
$30 a month inshallah tala.
Please
inshallah
support
everyone.